si bien qu'à 48 ans vous êtes
brutalement découverte
tragique regardez dans la glace
oh c'est pas tellement dans la glace que
je me suis regardée
en 1933 les années 30 sont à la mode je
suis un objet d'époque et je suis très
gai de ça
absolument pas chez les femmes je crois
que ce sont les femmes qui n'ont pas
réalisé tout ce qu'elle voulait quand
elles étaient jeunes je crois que une
femme qui a fait toutes les bêtises
humaines les plus gaies qui a bien
profité de la vie n'a pas peur de
vieillir vieillir c'est se reposer les
cheveux blancs se vieillissent
sûrement mais il faut les assumer c'est
à dire
c'est à dire les assumer dans sa tête
c'est un problème qui m'intéresse
énormément et enfin depuis que j'ai
tellement de cheveux blancs parce que
c'est arrivé assez vite dans le fond
avec 40 ans les 50 ans maintenant je me
promène dans la rue je vais dans les
magasins à la campagne partout parce que
c'est un vrai problème qui m'intéresse
beaucoup et je regarde que les gens qui
ont des cheveux blancs ont changé
entièrement tout leur comportement
brutalement brutalement ils ont des
vieux sacs ils ont des coiffures de
vieilles
ils ont un regard triste je veux dire
ces fameux cheveux blancs je vais
certainement Abraham comme si c'était
une frontière comme si c'était une
frontière et je pense que à partir du
moment où on la prend comme ça elle est
infranchissable
assumer ses cheveux blancs soit assumer
son visage et sans doute plus difficile
face aux autres et face à soi-même alors
de plus en plus nombreux sont celles et
ceux qui ont recours à la chirurgie
esthétique pour garder leur métier
conserver leur foyer ou simplement se
donner l'impression d'avoir stoppé le
temps
et là j'avais vous 50 je vais avoir 57
ans
alors bien sûr faire des robes à 57 ans
je pensais que les gens quand on vient
présenter des modèles peuvent se dire
mon Dieu
un certain âge elle ne peut plus faire
de robe jeune qui a rajeunissent alors
je me suis dit il faut effacer ça
absolument je ne peux pas continuer
comme ça et il y avait surtout mon coup
qui me gênait c'est bien que la
motivation était uniquement
professionnelle
en très grande partie oui et l'autre
partie
et bien un petit regret de la vie passée
de plaire encore
en me disant c'est dommage enfin ça
c'est mais c'est moins important quand
même c'était une chose moins importante
parce que je crois que un certain âge il
y a une autre personnalité qui doit
sortir alors donc ça c'était une chose
qui me tourmente et moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt par
rapport à moi qu'il était indispensable
de la faire il fallait que je perde des
pieds je perds des confiance je crois en
moi-même et si
je pense que si
cette chose je l'avais gardé ce manque
de confiance qui qui s'était un malaise
effectivement qui s'installait en moi et
bien c'est cela qui était important que
j'ai fasse si vous n'avez plus confiance
en vous si vous êtes si vous trouvez que
c'est la fin c'est terminé et bien
automatiquement les êtres s'écartent de
vous je pense
notre mission s'appelle la peur de
vieillir est-ce que cette opération a
supprimé cette peur ou à reculer cette
peur
peut-être que ça va revenir bientôt mais
je n'en sais rien mais reculer
certainement certainement lorsque vous
tous lorsque vous vous regardez de tous
les matins effectivement tous les matins
au réveil je me regarde je me dis oh mon
dieu pourvu que pourvu que mon cou ne
retombe pas
très bien les cicatriser très bien pour
que vous êtes en bonne santé
très bien nous allons voir l'autre côté
docteur de chirurgie esthétique est-elle
une mode ou un phénomène social
oh je crois que la chirurgie esthétique
est un phénomène social
elle est en rapport avec la peur de
vieillir et la peur de vieillir est une
chose qui est bien naturelle et bien
justifiée car on peut considérer que le
vieillissement
est visible de deux façons visibles pour
soi-même puisqu'on se voit devant son
miroir tous les matins et qu'on n'aime
pas se voir vieillir et puis les
visibles par rapport aux autres parce
que sont les autres qui vous voient
et là il y a une chose qui est très
importante c'est que le corps qu'on
modifie par la chirurgie esthétique et
vraiment la seule chose qui nous
appartiennent en propre quand nous nous
regardons le matin dans la glace et que
nous voyons des poches où nous voyons
des cernes nous voyons les rides il
s'agit de notre propre corps et tout
dans la vie dépend la plupart du temps
des autres ce sont la politique que ce
soit les affaires que ce soit le travail
il s'agit toujours de naître
intermédiaire tandis que notre corps
c'est nous-même donc nous prenons
nous-mêmes la décision de le faire cette
décision est très importante et
deuxièmement vis-à-vis des autres les
autres voient ce que nous nous voyons
dans notre propre miroir donc ce sont
deux raisons très importantes pour
essayer d'être au mieux de soi-même
j'avais remarqué il y a à peu près
dizaine d'années aux Etats-Unis en
faisant ces études justement à propos de
la chirurgie esthétique que en Amérique
on faisait beaucoup de rajeunissement
que les gens avaient peur de vieillir et
je croyais qu'avec un Amérique en Europe
je me rends compte que c'est la même
chose et récemment lors d'un voyage en
Russie à Moscou j'ai été visité
l'Institut de chirurgie esthétique qui
s'est ouvert à Moscou et j'ai appris que
chaque ville grande ville russe
possédait également un institut de
beauté avec un service de chirurgie
esthétique donc il part on peut penser
que cette peur de vieillir touche aussi
bien les hommes que les femmes et dans
tous les pays du monde qui sont
capitalistes socialistes je suis
aide-soignante dans une maison de
retraite
et nous n'avons pas le temps de faire du
discours malade nous n'avons pas le
temps de les écouter non plus alors le
plus souvent mes collègues moi nous nous
réfugions derrière un sourire
que l'on voudrait significatif
mais
pour ma part ça n'accrochait plus
et je me suis demandé pourquoi
et voilà ce que j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé
que mon sourire était semblable au
leurre mon sourire était le reflet de
leur propre misère c'est à dire
davantage une grimace qu'un sourire un
sourire de quelqu'un sur le
vieillissement
quelqu'un de marquer déjà par la vie
et je ne voyais pas de remède je
n'envoyais pas
quelque chose de nouveau je suis
heureuse
l'opération chirurgie esthétique
pour quelle raison à 39 ans je peux pas
faire une opération chirurgienne
esthétique ça dépend de la conception de
vie et de la vie que l'on a tout on a
mené et qu'on veut se faire qu'on veut
se recréer
beaucoup
je sentais que les rues tombaient ça ça
se voyait quoi je suis quand même
relativement respectueux de ma petite
personne finalement
vu comme moi mais enfin certains sont
polis quand même je sentais déjà 30 ans
vous avez vieilli donc il y a 10 ans
ça se voit finalement on voit si on a du
succès ou pas et puis lorsque les sucs
s'alimentent c'est tout ça se sent de
toute façon sur le plan sexuel on a
quand même une faute
par là à partir de 30 ans vraiment on
descend quand même on le sent bien on
fréquente plus les mêmes personnes parce
que le physique change
ça sent bien j'avais quand même beaucoup
moins d'aventures qu'avant je n'ai je
n'osais plus aller inviter les jeunes
filles dans les dans les dancing je sais
plus ce qu'on appelle draguer c'est pas
mais je me sentais à moindrée moi-même
je sais pas moi par semaine enfin vous
savez jamais été tellement Playboy
l'homme normal et qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un homme normal d'après vous donc
vivre et puis un jour cesse la vie
simplement un homme qui a plus ou moins
de ce qui a envie de vivre simplement de
fréquenter jeunes filles d'être sûr
d'être sûr de lui c'est ça je crois
l'homme normal pour moi et le fait que
soyez un homme ne vous a pas gêné pour
subir une obsède opération
de subir une intervention que l'on
attribue aux gens de féminine ça me gêne
pas pourquoi quelle importance est-ce
que votre vie a été changé
pour moi oui je me suis beaucoup mieux
senti dans ma peau finalement beaucoup
mieux et vis-à-vis des autres vis-à-vis
des autres
bon au départ
c'est demander pourquoi finalement et
lorsque j'ai expliqué on a compris et je
suis persuadé que de très nombreuses
personnes ont envie et non pas après un
coup de bistouri ou plusieurs coups de
bistouri est né un homme nouveau ah oui
un nouveau complètement nouveau un homme
content
de peau
il est arrivé quelque chose dans ma vie
d'affreux pour une femme j'ai perdu
l'homme que j'aime
ça s'est passé comment
je pense que il a commencé à me regarder
et à faire des différences
avec les autres femmes ou peut-être
regarder-il les femmes plus jeunes que
moi
avec plus d'intérêt j'ai commencé à me
douter de quelque chose j'ai commencé à
avoir peur je me voyais dans son regard
et ça n'était pas très joli et un jour
j'ai été mise devant le fait accomplie
on m'a annoncé que
c'était fini c'était pour une
femme une jeune femme de 30 ans
et ça a été
un coup terrible un échec sur tout
terrible
si bien que 48 ans vous êtes brutalement
découvertes
tragique regardez dans la glace on sait
pas tellement dans la glace que je me
suis regardé c'est dans quoi sinon
regardez un homme
[Musique]
le regard d'un homme le regard des
autres tout se joue là c'est vrai le
regard ou l'absence de regard
une femme qui n'est plus regardée par
l'homme qu'elle aime qui devient pour
lui transparente objet parmi les objets
familiers entre dans cet enfer dont La
Rochefoucauld parlait déjà à propos de
la vieillesse des femmes et dont la
médecine moderne établit les causes
détermine les raisons et auxquelles
elles cherchent des remèdes au centre du
problème la ménopause que les hommes ont
longtemps regardé comme une affaire de
bonne femme
notre émission s'appelle la peur de
vieillir est-ce que dans la conversation
le patiente le mot vieillir revient
souvent
oui à la ménopause certainement quand
elles sont entrées en ménopause elles
ont l'impression d'avoir vieilli d'un
coup elles ont l'impression d'avoir
vieilliami
sève qui s'en va comme une prairie
desséchée parce que l'eau n'arrive plus
elles ont l'impression des pieds à la
tête cheveux les yeux la peau même la
posture que d'un seul coup il leur
manque une sève une pulpe qu'elles
avaient et qui les quitte en trois mois
et c'est très difficile de supporter un
changement brutal de ce genre
ensuite elle se sentent terriblement
diminuée sur le plan des capacités
physiques mais même intellectuelles il y
a des des altérations de la mémoire qui
vont vraiment jusqu'au brouillard et
jusqu'à la gêne professionnel intense
alors
elles ont l'impression tout ça et liée à
la définition de la vieillesse elles ont
dans l'impression que la vieillesse leur
tombe dessus comme une chape de plomb
elle bascule le mot n'est pas trop fort
mais elle bascule pas dans un état
nouveau elle bascule dans une espèce de
gouffre d'un confort de malaise de perte
de sa personnalité de troubles de toutes
sortes dans lesquels les troubles
organiques ne sont pas les plus
importants en pourcentage combien de
femmes ont-elles ménopause difficile 15
à 20% ont une ménopause sans trouble
c'est très peu donc ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle ne présente pas tardivement des
atrophies importantes qui sont les
troubles c'est la partie spectaculaire
et gênante mais les atrophies ce sont
c'est la partie graves c'est ce qui va
faire les pathologies de vieillissement
oui je crois que j'ai été très fatiguée
il y a cela environ deux trois ans
braque avait été extrêmement active
jusque là j'étais enfin j'avais une
certaine nonchalance à vivre je voyais
les choses très très en noir j'étais
très pessimiste je sentais déjà que la
période désagréable est arrivé
effectivement je me suis sentie très
fatiguée je sors des difficilement de
mon lit le matin enfin des tas d'ennuis
de ce genre enfin pas très très grave
enfin tout de même et je suis tombée sur
deux ou trois ou quatre matins je ne
sais plus exactement maintenant qui
m'ont dit en même madame vous savez vous
allez rentrer dans une période difficile
toutes les femmes sont comme vous vous
allez prendre un ou deux médicaments en
format donné des médicaments qui ne
m'ont rien fait du tout d'ailleurs et en
me disant bah il faut que ça passe comme
ça ça doit normalement c'est comme ça
pour toutes les femmes parce qu'elle
n'avait pas l'air du tout les tracasser
loin du monde 45% des femmes en clinique
psychiatrique en tant que 45 et 55 ans
il est incontestable je ne saurais pas
vous dire des statistiques sur le
suicide mais il est un contestable que
cela conduit à des perturbations
caractériels qui ont sûrement été prises
pour des névroses pures alors qu'il y
avait une composante organique
considérable
et jusqu'à un stade qui est quelquefois
irréversible
en France ils sont plus de 330 000 ce et
celle Québec maison de retraite et
hospice en majorité des femmes bien sûr
puisque les femmes vivent en moyenne 8
ans de plus que les hommes le chiffre de
330 000 Françaises et Français en
hospice ira d'ailleurs en augmentant car
la médecine si elle prolonge la vie ne
garantit jamais l'intégrité physique et
intellectuelle
notre société de plus en plus fondée sur
l'égoïsme n'est d'ailleurs pas faite
pour les vieux
est-elle faite pour les jeunes
Monique pour une fille de 22 ans la
vieillesse qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
très loin non oui c'est c'est loin quand
on a 22 ans bien sûr mais la vieillage
je crois c'est c'est nous les jeunes en
ce moment on est je crois qu'on dit on
déjeune sont vieux les jeunes mais c'est
vrai puisqu'à 18 ans je me suis sentie
plus vieille qu'un vieux et cette idiot
à dire mais
je n'avais plus de but je enfin j'ai
voulu j'ai voulu en finir j'ai voulu
dormir pour toujours et je crois que que
la vieillesse c'est justement
enfin
c'est attendre la mort c'est bête mais
c'est ça on est vieux quand on attend la
mort parce qu'il y a des gens qui ont 80
ans et qu'ils sont très jeunes on dit
oui ils sont jeunes pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont toujours quelque chose à
faire parce qu'ils croient il croit la
vie et je crois que c'est ça et beaucoup
de jeunes en ce moment parce que j'ai 22
ans et je suis bien placé pour le savoir
beaucoup de jeunes sont vieux à mon avis
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de but
il n'attendent rien de la vie et tous
les dégoûtes donc ils choisissent des
orientations comme la drogue comme un
tas de bêtises enfin c'est peut-être des
bêtises mais c'est une explication
logique on a plus de buts on ne sait
plus où on va et pour moi c'est ça c'est
ça a été ça parce que ça n'est plus je
suis reparti pour pallier cet état de
néant j'ai eu un enfant maman
célibataire c'est
c'est pas bien vu mais enfin c'est c'est
moi c'est mon objectif disons c'est ma
fille pour m'aider à vivre à aimer la
vie et je crois que j'y arriverai enfin
je serais obligé de toute façon mais
quand on est conscient on se dit bon bah
après tout c'est chouette quand on a un
but
et moi c'est ma fille
[Musique]
peur de vieillir même ceux pour qui ça
n'existe pas pas encore parce qu'ils ont
20 ans et poussent les autres seront
donc un jour où l'autre saisi par cette
grande peur qu'il tenteront de maîtriser
comme il le pourront grâce à la
gymnastique
à la médecine à la chirurgie au voyage
ou à la culture des roses dans un jardin
de province
[Musique]